this video is kindly sponsored by
brilliant
find out more later in the video hey 42
here
some of humanity's greatest achievements
are so remarkable that the individuals
involved
will forever go down in history neil
armstrong was the first man to walk on
the moon
roald hamilton was the first to reach
the south pole
roger bannister ran the first sub four
minute mile
and yuri gagarin was the first person
in space this particular class of
firsts are different to most of the
other random statistics we humans like
to keep
track of usain bolt is the fastest man
ever to run the utterly arbitrary
distance 100 meters
but one day someone will do it faster
and bolt will have to pass his crown
onto a new owner neil armstrong on the
other hand
will still be the first member of our
species
to have walked on the moon untold eons
from now
at the heat death of the universe
admittedly
it's quite unlikely anyone will actually
care at that point
but you see what i'm getting at to do
something
first is to write your name indelibly
into humanity's
collective history book but there is one
famous first that's a little less set in
stone
than all the others brilliant is a
revolutionary problem-solving website
and
app that teaches you to understand the
logic
and methodology behind a problem rather
than giving you
essentially the same problem with
different values over and over
which doesn't really improve your
understanding with over 60 different
courses from the fundamentals of
mathematics
to special relativity and computer
programming
brilliant provides you with your daily
mental workout
and a good dose of self-improvement and
it's all delivered seamlessly through a
friendly
and undeniably beautiful user interface
as someone who's previously dabbled
rather heavily in computer programming
i was really interested how brilliant
approaches to teaching of computer
science
and i was not disappointed it didn't
just throw meaningless coding tasks at
me
instead it teaches you the fundamentals
that govern computer science
and now i genuinely feel like i
understand the underlying concepts of
computer science
better than ever before and why
computers and algorithms
behave in the way they do so if you're
looking to learn about computer science
or even excel in maths and science
brilliant will be there to help make you
brilliant go to www.brilliant.org
forward slash
42 to sign up for free and
the first 200 people will get 20
off their annual premium membership
in 1953 sir edmund hillary
and tenzing norgay did something
truly remarkable they became
the first humans to reach the very top
of the world the peak of mount everest
but some people believe this particular
first
was in reality a second
because it turns out mount everest may
in fact have been successfully climbed
almost 30 years before the date
currently recorded in the history books
by george mallory and andrew irvine
two members of the 1924
british expedition to everest
this is the story of the biggest
unanswered question
in the history of mountaineering one
that has endured for almost a century
who really climbed mount everest first
on the 8th of june 1924 george mallory
and andrew irvine
were making their bid for the summit of
the world's tallest mountain
irvine was just 21 at the time and a
relatively inexperienced mountaineer
but mallory was one of the best around a
veteran of two
previous everest expeditions and a minor
celebrity back home in britain
you may not be familiar with the name
but you've probably come across his most
famous quote
when asked by a reporter why he wanted
to climb everest
like an absolute boss mallory simply
replied
because it's there as the two men
toiled their way through the rarefied
air at the top of the world
another member of the expedition noel
odell was moving up everest
hundreds of meters below in a support
role
the mountain had been shrouded in mist
and cloud for most of the day
but around lunchtime the sky suddenly
cleared
odell squinted up against the sunlight
and there clinging to the side of the
mountain
he could just make out two tiny figures
his heart started to pump half a beat
faster
and not because of the effort of
breathing the thin air
malory and irvine had almost reached
the summit just as soon as the breaking
weather had arrived
it was gone and mallory and irvine
just specs against the snow disappeared
completely from view
noel odell didn't know it then but that
was to be the last time
his friends were ever seen alive
there has never been any doubt that
george mallory and
andrew irvine lost their lives shortly
after odell glimpsed them that day
the question was did they make it to the
summit of mount everest
before they met their end
it's hard to overstate just how
dangerous a place mount everest is
its peak rises a frankly ridiculous 8849
meters above sea level
that's 5.5 miles which is just about
getting into the territory
of cruise altitudes for commercial jets
to call the environment at that kind of
altitude challenging
would be like diving into a swimming
pool full of molten lava
and complaining that the water was a tad
warm
everest is so tall that the jet stream
regularly batters it bringing with it
winds
of up to 175 miles per hour
to put that into perspective gusts of
just 73 miles per hour
are considered hurricane force if you
ever fancy trying to climb the mountain
you'd better wrap up warm average
temperatures hover at around
-20 celsius in the summer and -35
in the winter you'll need your wits
about you too
because everest is going to attempt to
murder you at
regular intervals by burying you in
avalanches
dropping landslides down on your head or
luring you into one of the countless
crevasses that crisscrosses its glasses
but horrific weather temperatures that
would make your freezer feel
cozy and death by snow and dice
would actually be the least of your
worries if you ever did decide to brave
everest
because the top 10 percent or so of the
world's tallest mountain
pierces what is charmingly known as
the death zone at this altitude
generally considered to be
above 8 000 meters there simply isn't
enough oxygen to sustain
human life there's no acclimating
yourself to these conditions
if you're foolish enough to stay up that
high for long
you'll die in the death zone life
expectancy
is literally measured in hours despite
having been climbed over 8 000
times the longest anyone has ever
survived at the summit of mount everest
without supplemental oxygen
it's just 21 hours you may be thinking
that
it's no real surprise or squishy
hairless apes don't last long
up everest were hardly built for
physical extremes after all
i start to feel dangerously chilly if
someone accidentally leaves a window
open
but it isn't just us no non-microscopic
animal of
any kind is known to make its home in
the top
2 000 metres of everest slopes
not even plants can live this high the
last scraps of vegetation on everest
disappear at 6500 meters
well short of the summit put simply the
upper reaches of mount everest
are abhorrent to life as we know it
okay so hopefully i've painted a picture
that everest
is a sub-optimal holiday spot for those
looking to remain in possession
of a beating heart because all this
explains why it took so long for the
mountain to be climbed in the first
place
everest was first established as the
tallest mountain on earth
way back in 1852 but nobody got anywhere
near climbing it
for decades which brings me back to the
question
at hand who got there first
according to the official report from
the 1924 expedition
it was mallory and irvine though nobody
on the team had
definitive proof of a successful ascent
noel odell's sighting of the pair near
the summit
and the team's absolute belief in the
mountaineering brilliance of mallory
was enough to convince them the two men
had made it
before succumbing to the unrelenting
violence of the mountain
but over the years people began to
question the validity of that conclusion
odell claimed to have last sighted
mallory and irvine at what is now known
as
the second step a feature on everest's
northeast ridge
that would have been the single most
challenging section
of their entire route according to odell
the two climbs the steep rock of the
second step
in just five minutes something most
mountaineers believe
simply isn't possible in fact many in
the climbing community suspect the
second step
would have been beyond the skill level
of the two climbers entirely
it's so difficult that these days almost
everyone who summits everest by this
route
climbs the second step by way of a
ladder
and the difficulty of the climb wasn't
the only question mark against mallory
and irvine the pair were equipped with
all the state-of-the-art mountaineering
equipment of the day
unfortunately state of the art in 1924
was quite we're talking about a
time before the invention
of the television here the expedition
did carry a primitive oxygen setup
but it was their clothes that might have
really let them down
these days mountaineers wear cavernous
down-filled
jackets and over advanced technical gear
whereas mallory and irvine were decked
out in far
simpler garments of layered wool silk
and cotton that looked a bit like the
kind of thing
bear grylls might come up with if you
asked him to design a business suit
for a long time people have reasoned
that this kind of get up
simply wasn't up to the demands of
climbing everest
and the pair would have quickly
succumbed to the freezing temperatures
and biting winds that plagued the
mountain's peak
but whilst there were plenty of reasons
to doubt
whether mallory and irvine could really
have made it to the summit
there is also a persistent lingering
suspicion
that they may just have done it
for every argument against the pair
there was an equally believable argument
for for example perhaps the second step
was beyond
even mallory's prodigious climbing
ability
but that might not have actually
mattered because mallory is known to
have previously made use of a
mountaineering technique
that involves using your climbing buddy
as a kind of
human ladder it might sound a bit
fanciful that he could have cheesed such
a hard climb this way
but it turns out that's exactly how a
chinese expedition
did it when they made the first
documented ascent of the second
step in 1960 and if mallory had been
able to get through this section of the
climb
he would arguably have been odds on to
have made the summit
even if it meant leaving irvine behind
as for the team's lowly equipment and
old-fashioned clothing
carefully researched replicas of the
outfits used during the expedition
were tested on everest back in 2007
and were found to be perfectly adequate
for a summit bid
in fact the team carrying out the tests
who were all experienced mountaineers
found the archaic outfits to be
extremely comfortable
and much lighter than their modern
equivalents so
yeah there's never been enough concrete
evidence to
rule out the possibility that one or
both of mallory and
irvine made the summit the problem is
there's never been any concrete evidence
to prove that they did make it
either not that that stopped people from
trying to find some
in 1999 an expedition set out to retrace
mallory and irvine's steps
in the hopes of proving once and for all
whether or not they reached the summit
back in 1924 everest is
easily one of the most challenging
places on planet earth
to mount a search effort and yet
on the first day scouring their chosen
site
the team hit the jackpot because they
didn't just find a few subtle old clues
hidden here and there
they found george mallory
this is where i should probably point
out that bodies
aren't exactly uncommon on mount everest
more than 300 people have died on the
mountain
as their dreams of reaching the top
rapidly transformed into nightmares
but the atmosphere is so cold and dry
up there that bodies don't rot away
they freeze it's usually too dangerous
and costly to retrieve the dead and so
they're simply left there frozen corpses
are so common around everest's jagged
peak
that some of them like the one known as
green boots
have become grisly landmarks that help
climbers pinpoint
exactly where they are on the mountain
having said that finding malory who in
the years since the disappearance
had become a mountaineering legend of
almost
mythical proportions was huge
the body was frozen solid its skin
bleached pure white by the sun
but mallory was remarkably well
preserved
one of his legs was badly broken and he
had rope burns around his waist
suggesting he may have taken a fall
whilst attached to irvine
but he couldn't have fallen far as that
was the extent of his injuries
well aside from the deep puncture wound
at his temple
which was probably the cause of his
death it seems likely
mallory hits his head on a sharp rock
during the fall
though it's also possible his own ice
axe was responsible for the injury
as he frantically attempted to use it to
arrest his fall
with a technique known as a glissade
all of this was interesting stuff a
window into the last desperate seconds
of a legendary mountaineer
who died some 75 years before
but the big question remained did this
tragic accident happen on the way down
from the peak of everest
after a successful summit
well maybe because the 1999 expedition
did find a couple of pieces of evidence
hinting
that mallory might well have made it all
the way to the top of the world
before he died for starters
his goggles were found tucked away in
his pocket and
not on his head suggesting he may have
been descending the mountain
in the dark everest is a death trap at
the best of times
and wandering around on its desolate
windswept
slopes at night isn't the kind of thing
any experienced mountaineer would
contemplate
but anyone who's climbed everest will be
familiar with what's known as
summit fever a kind of pseudo condition
where climates start to get more and
more reckless
the closer they get to the prestige of a
successful summit
if mallory had felt he was close enough
to complete the climb
he may well have pushed on far longer
than was sensible
leaving him no choice but to descend in
the dark
after hitting the top the second clue
was even more intriguing
it was well known that mallory had kept
a picture of his wife with him
throughout the expedition with the
intention of leaving it
at the top of everest if he made the
summit plenty of things were found on
mallory's frozen corpse in 1999
a pocket knife an altimeter and several
handwritten notes
but no picture of course neither of
these clues
proves anything mallory may simply have
taken two pairs of goggles with him up
to the summit
with the set he was wearing being torn
from his head
in the violence of his final fall as for
the picture
it does seem unlikely that it somehow
dropped out of his pocket
but unlikely isn't the same as
impossible
and hey maybe he just forgot to take it
with him that day
although admittedly it wasn't found
amongst his possessions at the team's
camp
okay so this is usually the part of the
video where i tell you
we'll likely never know the truth of
what happened and that this one will
remain a mystery forever
but as it turns out there is
actually genuine hope we might one day
know for sure whether or not mallory and
irvine achieved their ultimate goal and
became the first humans ever to set foot
on the summit of mount everest
because along with the photograph of his
wife
something else was missing when
mallory's body was found in 1999
a camera mallory and irvine are known to
have taken
a kodak pocket camera with them on their
summit attempt
and remarkably experts from kodak
believe that if found there's a good
chance the film within will still be
viable
they've even provided instructions as to
how to handle the camera
if it is ever found to minimize the
chances of damaging the film
since the pair would certainly have
taken a picture of the momentous
achievement
had they been successful in reaching the
summit if the camera
is ever found it may well finally give
up everest's greatest
secret the fact that no camera was
located at mallory's final resting place
isn't too much of a surprise irvine was
in charge of the expedition's cameras
and was the more accomplished
photographer so it makes sense that he
would have been in charge of snapping
the big
moment unfortunately as of today
the location of irvine's body remains
unknown
but even here this strange tale offers a
few
tantalizing clues in 1979
a group of climbers were sharing stories
from their camp
high up on the slopes of everest when
one of them
chinese mountaineer wang hong mao
recalled having seen what he described
as an
old british dead at 8 100 meters
during an expedition four years earlier
as i've said dead bodies are a dime a
dozen on mount everest
but old british ones at the altitude and
location
wang'd described are not as it happens
it was wang's story that led the 1999
expedition to george mallory's body
but details wang had described the
position and orientation of the
corpse the type and location of the
injuries it had suffered
didn't match malory's body at all
leading many people to speculate that
wang
had actually found irvine
unfortunately nobody has ever been able
to ask him for more information
about the exact location in which he saw
the long dead climber
because he was killed in an avalanche on
everest
the very day after sharing his story
back in 1979 almost as though the
mountain was trying to protect
its last great secret expeditions still
periodically search for irvine's body
chasing
similar leads to wangs or checking out
promising sights after scouring
high-resolution satellite images
after all there's no doubt irvine is
still up there somewhere and with him
just maybe a camera containing a roll of
undeveloped film
that could quite literally rewrite the
history
of one of humanity's greatest
achievements
for now sir edmund hillary and tenzing
norgay's names
rightly deserve to be listed as the
first men to successfully summit mount
everest
but make no mistake there's every chance
that george mallory
and andrew irvine or perhaps mallory
alone
made it to the very top of the world
almost 30 years before then
[Music]
thanks for watching